we talked about maxi Cleveland his shot
being more arcus everybody knows that
this is going to bring a lot because one
is the activation of not a Jordan helps
them remember their pain defense he knew
always have to have you on the floor at
either the Bulls game
born and raised outside North America
eight is Dusen as an assistant in the
NBA the last 18 years gotcha - another
great pass to the Andre Jordan that's
going to be a talent to watch this year
by the beam throws it inside Jordan
hello let's call when warning or data
plays will on the defensa de inca
[Applause]
so it's gonna be fun barely deals get it
out look at that it's a good boy you
faked me out nut player likes to look
where the ball is Chicago's gonna do
anything as a team their backcourt
carries the nice finish by DeAndre grace
hands then back down walk your way back
to nice pass the ticket wall slam dunk a
basket and rain from Luca basket and
it's a one-shot game there were signs of
it last year when he averaged 17 points
a game and then a big jump here's a
pocket pass and Powell rolling to the
basket from will compile scores Lincoln
driving up Damian Dotson Wow
foul DeAndre short Asher Howell that he
fouled it looka baseline
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
towards the Indiana trip in January of
London's master what a jam by cleaver I
almost feeling good enough to show three
times
yes sir does he's an intangible guy
Marcus smarts from Flower Mound Marcus
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
deandre the way so it's not like it's
one towards your total getting ejected
in a game the deandre tentacle that's a
little bit as have made the port for
this one
you want to do didn't look tough right
here Lucas
[Applause]
when to the finish
- great dog excellent pass from Lucca
alleviates in this match to the Lando's
defense was wiping out Lucan with the
driving kick part one of the three
swings drove all the money for the three
Ball corner pocket
here's a look at extra five put in 2 for
3 from the floor he's now missed seven
straight shots maybe he could break the
drought ultimately spun away from the
shorter player because of the defensive
to be Andreea six point six boards for
Dedmon Fox tonight Elite Sacramento in
scoring Lucio car and leading
[Music]
violet
Andre Jordan even forgave down the
stretch
with Pablo he ghosted Jordan tower of
power up for a slam dunk so clever
yoky has 11 points in the first quarter
oh wow alley-oop from Luca Alper a foul
his first
doesn't look I'm sorry mark that he's
got to be able to see this but again for
really cool thing hype is real here you
see the past for the time of the game
Amba just 70 percent for the year who
missed one of these I'm pretty sure come
away with the loose ball
yeah that's the matchup I really want to
pay attention to is those big guys on
the inside post George for the doc
[Music]
short backing up points scored on this
Luke assist heart to DeAndre Jordan yep
didn't force anything just found a wide
open
DeAndre is done [ __ ] this two is five
from the field so far finds DeAndre
Jordan on the LOB for Dallas is back
playing backs back tomorrow in Philly as
Barnes breaks the snide as we concur
with you and know that myself and that
played just a moment ago with the ball
just went off Cletus book would be an
example of that as Brunson goes for the
second time repeat from this game that's
a three Ball corner pocket Mavericks
regain the lead his best offensive game
as a pro is against San Antonio last
December 9 10 for the floor 21 points in
that game and December 2017 and on cue
it's cleaver from the corner 11 points
point tonight
[Applause]
the great time
by luke reports six assists to the game
one of his better times tonight mark the
eye contact was there and Luca faces
that 37% from that three-point line so
they can make that call us it's
definitely part of that at 38% is the
alley-oop is tipped home by DeAndre
Jordan two defenders against Luke on the
sideline with Blanco incredible past
applause out of the corner and he hits
it at the double-team that he drew
Harrison Barnes wide open under which
side of the floor in spite of Toronto in
Boston in Philadelphia the big dogs in
the Eastern Conference Lucas back in and
he finds finney-smith for a quarter 3.73
Maps 70 that was hanging around outdoor
food facials second closer could drop
out by Luca give him another assist
seven straight games against the East
and six of Luca finds Dwight Powell just
came in for DeAndre Jordan
possessive that's pretty job
[Music]
Wilkinson deandre short the
Walker you hate that they cleaned up
that mess concerned they've just missed
a layup
Dorian finney-smith pass over the teacup
Nori's just gonna slip right to the
red-blue brush swing by Cleveland pass
it back foxy akka Luca got around
[Applause]
gonna give the ten desist that's a point
five
not living on the outside he got in the
lane grapevine that time for Jordan soft
pass in special heads I asked Rick today
it shoot around what happened then
can't happen tonight as spitting Smith
Rosa Corona three off the path do you
miss eleven free throws on Sunday in a
game you lost
he had a good read on that shot now
Lucca works against Shetty Osman nice
fire and again this time in the other
corner protocol from Luca that ass heart
beats blind pass last minute off defeat
defense start guarding to God that every
now and then can come up with some big
things as he crimps home the alley new
baccala problem gun la Luca then
finished what hand by clean up well
that's good vision because the minute
his defensive guy came in front of Luca
he'd arrived lobbed it up to Cleveland
Luca is made threes for Dallas of the
firstborn in a franchise record for most
threes made threes yes Jay made a lot of
sleeves outstanding
on a cutting bowel to the rim ready with
11 assists there's a fine there's the
finish when their backcourt is joined
it's the best time to knock one off yep
down the baseline on the past by Luca
[Applause]
jr. with the catch and finish this is
down to a one-shot game now the lob pass
ad on Chooch perfect tomorrow a last
game for hard right to Powell difficult
finish for Powell right there hopefully
you get it no points I have added on the
school board for the Rockets either on a
mystery by heart short clock my spine
here yes it was POW catches from Luca
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I spy maybe another assist yes
[Applause]
was a good job he's an energy player my
spine Oh passive Powell inside with a
score excellent vision that time by
Lucas quarters Luke has been scoring and
then when he's looked to make passes do
I cut bitchin Mike shed a nerd chitchat
harp about Dallas's recent third quarter
struggles as Powell scores again from
Luca I see from the three-point line 41
for the mass Luca probing good find in
the corner looked off the defense and
Lee has tied the game quarter 3 Courtney
Lee and with all due respect as Houston
who certainly they are playing very very
well recently as paljah scored from Luca
Trevor Ariza is missed down into the NBA
working his way in the painted Aaron
Gordon was looking for Vukovich and a
batted away pass it set by the handsome
Luca running the floor and flushing is
too white Powell of course Luke is gonna
set you up it's a waiter pass right
there easy finish for Dwight pop-up you
pass John Stockton to 3rd in NBA history
look out lobbing it for battery and
attempt of the foul huh Lucas serving up
his buddy Salaam measuring second to
Golden State and offensive rating this
year scoring over a hundred and fourteen
points per 100 possessions as two white
pal drills the three
the passive looking fine to keep Houston
under a hundred uses scored 100 plus and
19 straight games
the unfortunate thing though is there
has have been enough office there for
Dallas tonight without a duck by Powell
off the feed from Luka who's still
limping rather noticeably clinic
offensively
Devon Harris and confetti she how about
that late pass there is lead up the game
now for the Spurs and you know you look
at the Spurs team and we were talking
about fishing
then he Smith in the corner for three I
love what Dallas is doing with Brunson I
mean he's a leader
and not only is he a natural leader but
he's also a guy that can score the
basketball playing terrific second jeans
one maker usually the shop with the mesh
townships they've got numbers for on to
[Applause]
really shock here's the drive to the
basket by Luca where mine said OPA Jalen
Brunson and that was takes the lead in
overtime thanks to the Crutzen
three-pointer Luca Paolini Valencia
tenth assist at the triple-double for
Luca Luca eyeballed the realm
thought about the three gonna drive and
go cross-court to Cleveland he nails a
three he's starting for Dallas 49% from
the floor they shoot as a team to lead
the lead Betty Smith
that's an assist for Luca on the basket
by finney-smith three-point play
opportunity for him we start his bode
well for the Mavs offensive Lee is it
greedy to ask for a first half
triple-double from Luca he's one rebound
and 4 assists away it's greedy 24 points
11 boards looking for a system games
right yes and then there's been a couple
of those yeah yeah close shaves
[Applause]
James Johnson is the defendant against
Luca Lucas has hit a couple of step back
threes and what a pass off the dribble
and absolutely inside the solid seven
years old he's certainly going out as
harp said earlier still playing very
well Hassan Whiteside scum in a moment
ago for Miami and as a cross-court pass
and Brian broke off 14 of his last 20
finishing with the funky was dumped and
the first points of the game
there's going to be a thunderous dunk
for the members that odds are it's
Dwight Powell doing the damage when it
comes to scoring tonight look at 20
Malik seen the top what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content